merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre Colona mes chers collègues
après la visite du président Macron en
août 2022 en Algérie suivi de la visite
de la première ministre accompagnée de
16 de ses ministres après la visite de
Monsieur Darmanin en décembre 2022 qui
nous explique à son retour que tout va
bien et qui supprime les mesures de
l'imitation à 50 % de délivrance de visa
pour la France il semble que nous ayons
tout lâché mais pour quel résultat
les délivrances de laisser passer
consulaire de l'Algérie pour les occf
était déjà extrêmement faibles moins de
1% et avec le rappel de son ambassadeur
en France le 8 février 2023 l'Algérie
via ses 18 consulats sur notre
territoire annonce inédits ne plus
délivrer un seul laisser passer
consulaire et menace de suspendre la
délivrance des visas pour les Français
souhaitant se rendre en Algérie je
t'aime moi non plus ou en sommes-nous
madame la ministre ou en sommes-nous de
la main tendue et de cette repentance
incessante envers l'Algérie où sont les
résultats la réforme de votre ministère
qui écarte des diplomates chevronnés de
véritables négociateurs et bâtisseurs de
pont entre nos pays respectifs
commencent à faire vaciller toute un
édifice à quand des mesures fortes pour
une France forte et respectée des
mesures de restauration existent et sont
pourtant simples suspendent la
délivrance des visas aux Algériens
souhaitant se rendre en France
parallélisme des formes et égalité
traitement ni plus ni moins
pour répondre la parole la madame la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur avec l'Algérie nous avons
initié une dynamique ambitieuse depuis
la visite d'amitié du président de la
République les 25 26 et 27 août 2022
suivi de la réunion du cinquième
Comité intergouvernemental de haut
niveau sous l'autorité de madame la
Première ministre et de son homologue
les 9 et 10 octobre 2022 et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur sénateur le ministre de
l'Intérieur s'est ensuite rendu en
Algérie le 17 décembre dernier et je
note aussi vous l'avez oublié la visite
en France du chef d'état-major de
l'armée algérienne une première depuis
bien longtemps
alors monsieur le sénateur il faut
éviter de tomber dans le piège de ceux
qui souhaitent faire échouer notre
ambition ce n'est pas votre vœu j'en
suis sûr alors nous allons continuer à
travailler avec les autorités
algériennes à la levée des difficultés
constatées car la profondissement de
notre relation est dans l'intérêt de nos
deux pays et c'est dans cet esprit que
la France traite notamment de la
question de la migration entre l'Algérie
et la France cela concerne les visas
avec un groupe de travail conjoint qui
doit favoriser les mobilités notamment
entre les jeunes et en particulier les
jeunes professionnels mais cette
coopération oui pour être cohérente doit
également permettre d'assurer le retour
en Algérie des Algériens en situation
irrégulière comme le droit le commande
et ça fait partie de nos priorités
immédiates nous y travaillons nous y
travaillons notamment avec le président
teboun dont je suis sûr monsieur
sénateur que vous aurez noté avec
intérêt les dernières déclarations
si la visite du président algérien te
donne en France s'est confirmé en mai
prochain il sera toujours temps de
remettre le sujet sur la table avec
fermeté enfin je crois opportun de
rappeler que la naïveté peut-être
considérée comme de la faiblesse non
madame la ministre nous ne voulons pas
d'une France qui se couche mais d'une
France qui se fait respecter merci
[Applaudissements]